JANET RANKIN: The
beach ball strategy
is a way to get
students who might not
want to answer questions
or be a little less
outgoing in their answering of
questions to answer questions.
So there's a few different
ways to use the beach
ball, actually.
And one is you just
pose a question
that has enough variation
in the types of responses.
So you wouldn't say
OK, what's 2 plus 2
as an example for the
beach ball question.
You would have to have something
that was a little bit richer.
And then you throw the
ball at one student
or up into the lecture hall,
if it's a big lecture hall.
And whoever catches
it has to respond.
And that response, you
share it with the group,
comment on it if you
want to comment on it.
And then that person who gave
the first response throws
the ball to somebody else.
And then whoever catches
the ball that time responds,
et cetera.
You can use it coupled with
a picture prompt or a graph.
So if you show a graph
or an image and you say,
tell me something you
observe about this image,
and then you throw the
ball and the person
catches it first says one thing
they observe, and they throw it
and the next person
says something
that they observed about
the picture prompt.
So that gives a
foundation and it opens up
space for lots of responses.
The beach ball
does a few things.
One is that as the
instructor, you
don't have to be the one
that calls on the students
all the time, so
the students don't
feel like you're picking
on them, that you're
the one that's cold
calling on them.
And in fact you can throw on
the beach ball completely blind
the first time, close
your eyes, throw the ball,
and so nobody really feels
that you've called on them.
And then subsequently,
it's other students that
are throwing the
ball, so there's
no issue that you're the one
that's picking on the students.
The other thing is
it's kind of fun,
you're throwing the ball around,
so it's hard to get upset,
it's hard to get as
a student nervous
that you're going to have
to answer the question.
And in fact, you
could dodge the ball
if you really didn't want
to answer the question.
So it's a great way to
get students talking.
And in general, it's pretty fun.
And at first I thought
oh, I can't really
use this with grad
students, it's too goofy,
it's too baby or silly.
But actually,
every time I use it
with grad students,
postdocs, everybody
seems perfectly fine with it.
I think it's more to do with
the nature of the question.
If you just ask stupid questions
and throw the ball around,
it'll be stupid.
But if you ask good
questions and it's
a way for students to
give you their answers,
then it seems to
work totally fine.
That's the general way.
Sometimes I'll actually write
questions on the beach ball
and then throw the
ball into the class.
And then students
are loosely supposed
to answer the question
that's in front of them
when they catch the ball.
So that's another way to do it.
But it's a nice, inexpensive,
fairly flexible technique.